a relationship that hasn't lasted quite
as long as the one between the steelers
and ben roethlisberger continues in san
francisco jimmy garoppolo the starting
quarterback under contract for two more
years plenty of speculation about the
49ers looking to upgrade john lynch the
team's general manager appearing on the
i test for two podcast with clark judge
and ira kaufman had this to say about
jimmy garoppolo's immediate future
if he's injury-free is there any doubt
in your mind that jimmy garoppolo is
your quarterback when you line up in
september
no not at all i mean i i really believe
that he uh you know i just look at the
numbers i mean he's 25 and 24 9 25 and 9
when he's played um you know that being
available is a big part of this thing so
like i said we we probably as a
stated goal we have to insulate
ourselves better and we got to have
better options if he's not there
um
but you know i've i've watched people go
through this in the career where they
struggle it happened to me early and
then i went eight years without missing
a practice so i believe that things can
happen i i believe they will for him and
you know i really believe that jimmy is
our guy
i am reminded of the classic opening
argument in the trial at the conclusion
of my cousin vinnie when joe pesci's
character says everything that guy said
is
bs but he didn't say bs and he said
thank you and the entire opening
argument was then stricken from the
record except thank you john lynch said
what he had to say he said what he had
to say he's not going to come out and
say we're looking for an upgrade he's
not going to say that because then you
undermine your guy before you get your
upgrade and you also undermine your
ability to get an upgrade you have to
play it cool you have to like he act
like he's our guy he's due to make 25
million this year chris no one's paying
him 25 million if no one's paying big
ben 19 million no one's paying jimmy g
in his 23 missed games over the last
three years 25 million not this year no
maybe not but it's still a very
manageable number it's not to me that
won't be the thing
that ends up getting him off the san
francisco 49ers or anything like that
listen he doesn't have to say they're
looking to upgrade we know jimmy knows
we we know we've heard they were in the
market for matthew stafford you know we
hear the rumblings about the desean
watson so
okay those two yes
if you can get those two quarterbacks i
mean listen
jimmy g's gotta be somewhat realistic
here and go well yeah i'm i'm good but
i'm not matt stafford to desean watson
so i understand the team looking at that
he's got to have that realization there
let alone to know that i have been
injured but after you get to those two
guys
i mean
i i don't there's nobody out there right
now you can sit there and just go
they're definitively better than jimmy g
right i mean at least not to me i mean
sam darnold was if he became available
in the jets that certainly would be a
good conversation and i think he does
bring you know physical tools to the
field that maybe jimmy g does not have
jimmy g is a fringe
top half of the league quarterback 16
through 20 somewhere in there all right
and of course he knows the system the
team does like him
and
i i guess what i'm saying is i think
they're gonna stick with jimmy g unless
something gets presented to them that's
just obvious and and i think the other
thing that he said that was interesting
there mike and the big thing and this is
to me where you know the 49ers really
got to do this
no more cj beathards and and though and
nick mullins that's over bye see you
later we need to get somebody in there
that is a proven commodity to a degree
you got to protect your team this year
we can't just go with those guys whether
that's an andy dalton or a ryan
fitzpatrick or somebody like that that's
on the market you've got to have at
least a good backup behind jimmy g this
year to protect your team and to protect
their jobs shanahan and john lynch
yeah i agree with you and the other side
of it too we can't just gloss over the
23 missed games no the games he missed
in 2018 with a direct result of
stupidity on his part misguided machismo
when he's getting toward the sidelines
he decides he wants to drop a shoulder
and deliver a blow instead of getting
the hell out of bounds and he tears his
ac out i remember watching that with you
we thought he hurt his shoulder right
right he thought he had his shoulder
yeah and he's got a torn acl because he
had to be a tough guy and and plant his
leg and deliver a blow and blow out his
knee in the process that's all on him
and john lynch compared garoppolo's
struggles to stay healthy with lynches
lynch is out there throwing his body at
anything that moves garoppolo plays the
position that is in bubble wrap relative
to other positions there's no excuse for
not being available each and every week
yes there can be a fluke like bernard
pauler coming in low and coming in hot
and tearing tom brady's acl to start the
2008 season when pollard was playing for
the chiefs and brady was gone just like
that
but
it's injuries it's it's and it's it's
got it's got to be a factor when you
assess who else is available
one of the big check marks in favor of
the alternative option
is we think this guy can line up and
play i mean look i don't think the
vikings are going to move kirk cousins
because they don't have a better
alternative but i think if cousins was
available
i think your guy kyle would jump on him
in a heartbeat and you know what cousins
doesn't miss games cousins lines up and
plays every since he does cousins knows
how to avoid taking big hits and getting
himself pretzeled up and getting himself
injured yeah
i don't disagree with what you said
there i mean cousins is a clear upgrade
from jimmy g in my opinion you know we
just talked yeah i think cousins like we
said yesterday he's a fringe top 10
quarterback you know in that area where
we just talked jimmy g at least for my
money is somewhere between 16 21
somewhere like that so there is a
difference there and headless and the
injury thing you know you can be unlucky
you can be unlucky to what john lynch is
saying you know to a degree hey my my
own father his the first five years of
his career he battled injury now you
know the quarterback position was a lot
different then there was no rules to
protect you but you know he did have
that little stigma around him and then
1984 fifth year of his career comes
around and all of a sudden he kind of
justified it but this is
the play you're talking about kansas
city last year you know of course
against the new york jets and then let's
not forget in his chance during the
suspension for tom brady he got hurt in
the this the first half of the second
game he started for them that year too
so that would worry me there's no doubt
about that but i think where they stand
with everything the where their team is
at
you know i expect jimmy g to be their
quarterback unless
something just obvious presents itself
and to me right now the only thing out
there that's actually obvious is deshawn
watson and the 49ers traded away picks
last year to get an extra pick in the
first round you know i don't know if
they have the assets to make that type
of move they're probably gonna have to
they probably have to trade a number of
players on their team to try to get to
sean watson and i don't know if it's
worth it to do that either so uh they're
they're i think they're gonna have jimmy
g back uh unless something shocking
happens but the big thing is
and to your point
they gotta have an insurance policy this
year you got to you can't roll the dice
on a guy that yo he's young and i like
him and i think he could be something no
we need something we know and he can
come in and your team won't miss a beat
if jimmy g does go down
the jets reportedly are going to explore
all of the options that will be
available to them at quarterback in the
draft before deciding what to do with
sam darnold the third overall pick in
2018. yeah if the jets decide we're
gonna take a quarterback whether it's
zach wilson or someone else right second
overall pick and sam darnold is
available is he an upgrade in your mind
over jimmy g yeah that off as a as a yes
he is uh he is you know uh sam darnold
lightning quick release
and he is awesome in the pocket he is
awesome he is like a a manny pacquiao in
the pocket the way he can hop around and
do things like that to where yeah i
think he is an upgrade you know as a
player over jimmy g i i definitely do
and listen i think this is going to end
up being a real possibility because
zach wilson
i mean just just
i'm in the earliest zach wilson is
really impressive mike it's really
impressive the gap between him and
trevor lawrence is not as great as i
thought just after watching really
basically some highlight type
film on them the last few days it's not
as great as i thought and i'm interested
to dive in here because it's a little
closer than i thought it was going to be
too wilson's got some this kid's got
something to him there's no doubt about
it he's got some pizzazz some flair an
awesome arm and he's got this mahomes
magic so i would think the jets are
gonna watch film with zach wilson and go
whoa wait do we want to take this guy
and th this is this is something to
watch out for here over you know the
next few weeks or months or as we lead
up to the draft
can't help but wonder whether or not the
texans are going to watch film and say
do we want to take the second overall
pick from the jets and give them to sean
watson plus whatever else the jets would
give us for deshaun watts that's a good
exact question
wake up to that that could change
dynamics for a lot of teams but but
here's here's the bottom line right if
and when the 49ers upgrade over
jimmy g
it's not like anyone is going to bash
john lynch over the head with the words
that he used
recently no about jimmy g
just yeah but he said what he had to say
under the circumstances no different
than carson wentz being referred to by
howie roseman on january 4 as a finger
on your hand and then chopping that
finger off weeks later you say what you
have to say
given the circumstances you find
yourself in and they gain nothing by
saying well you know what if we could
find an upgrade over jimmy g he wouldn't
be the quarterback week one you're gonna
say until you have the two in the bush
in your hand right that the bird in the
hand is the one who is going to be
running the offense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports